huit textes la plupart des projets de
loi ratifie des ordonnances que j'avais
déjà eu l'occasion de vous présenter
dans des précédents compte rendu et donc
je vais passer très brièvement dessus
sont des projets de loi qu'ils ratifient
ces ordonnances premiers textes relatifs
aux régulateurs des redevances
aéroportuaires pour adapter notre droit
à la baisse du trafic aérien liée à la
crise sanitaire à notre texte qui
définit les modalités de création la
collectivité européenne d'alsace en
matière de travail nous avons examiné un
projet de loi ratifiant les ordonnances
qui permettent le maintien de l'activité
partielle ainsi que les ajustements de
notre droit du travail en matière de
prêt de main d'oeuvre et de congés payés
sas à l'épidémie nous sommes également
penchés sur le projet de loi ratifiant
l'ordonnancé relative à l'organisation
des concours et examens pendant la crise
sanitaire
et enfin le dernier projet de loi
ratifiant une ordonnance un texte qui
permet aux organismes de gestion des
droits d'auteur d'aider directement les
artistes auteurs et interprètes privés
de revenus ce texte permet également aux
salles de spectacles et de sport de
proposer des remboursements sous forme
d'avoir à leurs clients en plus de ces
textes
le premier ministre a présenté ce matin
un projet de loi particulièrement
important puisqu'il s'agit du projet de
loi prorogeant l'état d'urgence
sanitaire comme vous le savez l'épidémie
nous contraint à prendre des décisions
exceptionnelles des décisions difficiles
pour limiter la circulation du virus
protéger nos hôpitaux et sauver des vies
cet état d'urgence sanitaire qui
autorise le gouvernement à agir est
assorti d'un retour régulier devant le
parlement cela est conforme à notre
conviction d'une nécessaire association
des parlementaires à la gestion de cette
crise notre devoir démocratique aussi
c'est ce que nous faisons depuis le
début de cette crise ces derniers mois
nous avons vous le savez débattu et
discuter de nombreuses heures devant le
parlement qu'il s'agisse de la stratégie
de vaccination ou de textes liés à cet
état d'urgence sanitaire
lors du dernier examen l'état d'urgence
sanitaire avait été prolongée jusqu'au
16 février
nous devons donc être prêt et disposé de
moyens adaptés
face à la crise c'est ce que permet ce
projet de loi qui prolonge donc l'état
d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'au 1er juin
il permet de prendre des mesures qui
s'imposent pour freiner l'épidémie
ensuite nous sommes également penchés
sur le projet de loi autorisant la
ratification de l'accord portant
extinction des traités bilatéraux
d'investissement entre états membres de
l'union européenne
c'est un traité bilatéral bilatéral
d'investissement est un traité conclu
entre deux états qui encadre les
investissements entre eux et qu'ils
permettent souvent le recours à
l'arbitrage en cas de difficulté et la
rave achmea de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne a mis fin à ce type
vous traiter entre états membres de
l'union et cette décision permet
d'assurer que le droit de l'union
européenne s'applique uniformément est
partout et puis le ministre de l'europe
et des affaires étrangères a présenté un
texte relatif au système des ressources
propres de l'union européenne c'est un
texte extrêmement importants historiques
et je veux vraiment le dire
il permet à l'union européenne un plan
il permet à l'union européenne
d'emprunter en son nom 750 milliards
d'euros et ainsi de mettre en place un
plan de relance exceptionnel dont je
bénéficie tous les états membres
c'est une étape décisive dans la
construction européenne c'est la preuve
d'une europe qui agit face aux crises
qui prend son destin en main qui est
capable collectivement de se mettre
autour d'une table pour relever des
défis historiques comme celui que nous
sommes en train de vivre c'est le
symbole d'une europe au service des
nations car grâce à cette en train vous
le savez 40% du plan de relance français
sera financée par l'europe
voilà mesdames messieurs ce que je
pouvais vous dire du conseil des
ministres et du séminaire gouvernemental
auparavant je me tiens maintenant à
votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
bonjour anne yanis baume de bloomberg
news une question économie le groupe
canadien couche tard est en pourparlers
avec carrefour pour une offre
d'acquisition
j'imagine que cette actualité n'a pas
échappé à l'oeil attentif du
gouvernement dans la mesure où carrefour
est l'un des plus gros employeur privé
de france avec environ 100000 cdi dans
le pays
comment est-ce que le gouvernement
accueille t-il cette offre de la part de
couche tard
alors c'est une actualité qui n'a
évidemment pas échappé à l'oeil attentif
du ministre de l'économie des finances
et de la relance ce bruno le maire mais
pour ce qui est du porte parole du
gouvernement
n'ai pas de commentaire à faire vous de
réponse à vous apporter en revanche le
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la relance répondra à vos questions
sur le sujet par l'intermédiaire de son
équipe
bonjour violence violence des dames ou
de la fp alors j'ai deux questions
d'abord sur le séminaire est ce que vous
avez un peu lister les réformes que le
gouvernement et le président compte
effectivement faire dans les derniers 18
mois du quinquennat notamment sur les
retraites le grand âge qui était quand
même les deux réformes en suspens et
deuxième question sur la vaccination
si on arrive à un million fin janvier au
rythme d'un million parle moi ça ferait
trois ans de vaccins pour vacciner 30 à
40 millions français dont j'imagine
qu'il ya une accélération prévu et si
oui est-ce que vous avez une idée du
calendrier puisque maintenant certains
pays commencent à fixer des échéances
beaucoup plus précise sur quand ils
pensent avoir vacciné
la plupart où l'essentiel des gens
remercie alors sur votre première
question je rappelle l'objectif de ce
séminaire partager ensemble les grandes
priorités du gouvernement dans les mois
qui viennent nous avons d'abord abordé
la question la gestion des crises crise
économique crise sanitaire évidemment
les difficultés sociales c'était la
première partie de ce séminaire ensuite
nous avons abordé les réformes et les
projets de transformation qui seront
portées dans les tout prochains mois qui
sont déjà à l'agenda avec une discussion
politique sur d'autres projets qui
pourraient être portées nous avons
ensuite abordé la question de
l'évaluation et des résultats avec la
présentation du baromètre que ma
collègue vous a présenté et puis un
point sur la présidence française de
l'union européenne vers je n'ai pas
mentionné dans mon compte rendu tout à
l'heure mais ça a été un point important
de ce séminaire qui nous a permis de
partager sur nos grandes priorités dans
le cadre de cette présidence française
évidemment la question de l'agroécologie
la question du contrôle de nos
frontières et la question migratoire
la question économique et financière
seront
grande priorité dans le cadre de cette
présidence française mais là aussi à
l'occasion d'une communication et
quelques semaines j'avais eu l'occasion
d'en parler devant vous abordez vous
citez de réforme la réforme des
retraites et la réforme du grand âge et
de l'autonomie évidemment qu'elles ont
été abordés à l'occasion de ce séminaire
je lui dis je le disais à l'instant la
grande priorité des prochaines semaines
c'est la gestion de la crise sanitaire
et de la crise économique
il ya un certain nombre de réformes
évidemment qu'ils sont inscrits
notamment au parlement qui donc se
poursuivre des réformes qui dépendent
pas du parlement et du législatif mais
qui vont être menées notamment le bon
goût de la sécurité pour le reste il y à
des réformes qui avaient été engagées
qui évidemment reste à l'agenda de ce
quinquennat dès lors que nous serons
parvenus à maîtriser l'épidémie dans
notre pays et la situation sanitaire
la crise sanitaire n'a pas balayé la
nécessité de réformer de transformer
notre système de retraite bien au
contraire
bien au contraire dans les inégalités
qu'elle a révélé face à la retraite dans
des questions financières et économiques
évidemment aussi et donc je vous redis
que sur ces deux réformes que vous avez
évoqué elle reste évidemment à l'agenda
de ce quinquennat dès lors que la
situation des sanitaires nous permettra
de les reprendre mais je pense que les
français comprennent bien que
aujourd'hui notre boussole c'est
évidemment la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire et leur protection face à ce
risque
sur la question de la vaccination que
vous avez abordé je rappelle que la
stratégie vaccinale a été présenté par
le premier ministre devant le parlement
le 16 décembre dernier qui a eu ensuite
un certain nombre de conférences de
presse qui ont été faites et qui ont
exprimé clairement notre objectif
évidemment on a toujours été très clair
sur le fait que la première phase la
première étape du mois de janvier était
une première étape avec un nombre de
doses que nous recevons qui est le même
que nos voisins européens mais
qu'ensuite parce que nous allons
recevoir davantage de doses et parce que
nous l'espérons un certain nombre de
vaccins qui promettent d'autres modes de
conservation et de transport que le
vaccin files heures du one tech c'est à
dire la possibilité de le dispenser plus
largement en ville nous pourrons
évidemment aller sur 1
true grit puisque comme vous dites est
effectivement si on plaque et à ce
rythme-là sur l'intégralité de la
campagne vaccinale
nous n'atteindrons pas nos objectifs qui
sont je le rappelle de vacciner 15
millions de personnes vulnérables dans
les prochains mois ce sont les deux
premières phases
évidemment si nous pouvons aller plus
rapidement plus vite parce que nous
recevons les doses pour cela et parce
que nous avons maxine et nos publics
prioritaires nous ferons bien évidemment
mais sur ces questions là comme sur
l'épidémie de kobe 19 et la gestion de
l'épidémie le premier ministre ministre
de la santé auront l'occasion de revenir
sur ce point lors de la conférence de
presse de demain
j'imagine qu'à quand même d'autres
questions sur le sujet je vais essayer
d'y répondre justement peau poursuivre
pas sur la crise sanitaire mais sur la
réforme des retraites celle de la
dépendance aussi vous dit
reste à l'agenda et nous les remettrons
sur la table dès lors que nous serons
sortis de la crise sanitaire si encore
le président se sera pas avant au moins
au mieux la fin de l'été ça laissera
très peu de temps pour mener des
réformes aussi importantes et complexes
pour parler clair moi ce que vous voulez
réserver pour un éventuel second cas
kent moi je franchement je crois avoir
été assez transparent sur notre état
d'esprit vis à vis de ces réformes
ça reste une priorité pour nous de ce
quinquennat à l'agenda de ce quinquennat
parce que nous l'avons portée dans le
cadre de la campagne électorale parce
que ce sont des réformes qui sont
nécessaires parce que encore une fois la
crise sanitaire n'a pas balayé leurs
nécessités
bien au contraire maintenant encore une
fois je pense que les français peuvent
comprendre que aujourd'hui c'est la
gestion de l'épidémie et la relance de
notre économie qui sont notre grande
priorité
je ne peux pas vous dire quand
l'épidémie sera derrière nous évidemment
je souhaite comme nous tous que ce soit
le plus rapidement possible et nous
faisons tout pour ans et l'arrivée du
vaccin est un immense espoir pour nous
permettre d'y parvenir dans les
prochains mois et dès lors que nous y
serons parvenus nous pourrons reprendre
un certain nombre de réformes
sylvie corbet ap ça fait maintenant une
dizaine de jours que le couvre-feu a été
étendu à dix-huit heures dans certains
départements est ce que vous avez fait
une évaluation de la mesure et en clair
est-ce que c'est l'apéro entre amis qui
est visé alors d'abord oui
je rappelle que le couvre-feu en tant
que telle a été examiné a été évalué par
des scientifiques
il ya eu une étude de santé publique
france sur le couvre-feu qui avait été
mis en place avant le 2è confinement
donc à la fin octobre et qui a montré
que le couvre-feu était un instrument
efficace pour lutter contre la
circulation du virus
précisément parce qu'il permet de
limiter les interactions sociales que
l'on peut avoir en fin de journée dans
les domiciles privés par exemple et donc
le choix d'avancer ce couvre-feu à 18
heures dans un certain nombre de
départements vise évidemment à limiter
encore davantage ces interactions c'est
une décision difficile qui est difficile
pour les français concernés difficile
pour les commerçants évidemment nous
n'avons en tête et quand nous prenons ce
type de décisions ou les prenons parce
que c'est nécessaire pour des raisons
sanitaires et pour freiner la
circulation du virus dans notre pays et
je rappelle qu'il y avait eu un
précédent même si je fais toujours très
attention en comparant les territoires
de la république ils ont chacun leur
spécificité mais en guyane nous avions
avancé le couvre-feu dans l'après-midi à
l'époque où il avait été mis en place et
on avait vu des effets très fort pour
répondre à votre question très
concrètement disons le plus concrètement
possible tout en sachant que demain
c'est des sujets sur lesquels olivier
ferrand notamment pourra revenir
nous avons abordé cette question de
l'évaluation et de l'impact du
couvre-feu à 18 heures dans les
départements où il a été mis en place il
ya maintenant un certain temps je pense
que c'était le 2 janvier et ce qui nous
a été rapporté par le ministre de la
santé c'est que manifestement il y a un
effet sur la circulation du virus de
l'avancement du couvre-feu à 18 heures
et ce qui nous a été démontrée ce matin
à l'appui de données
et de statistiques c'est que dans les
départements où le couvre-feu a été
avancée à 18h au tout début du mois de
janvier la circulation du virus est
moins importante que dans d'autres
départements français c'est-à-dire qu'il
croît moins vite
la dynamique de croissance du virus est
moins rapide que dans d'autres
territoires mais évidemment c'est trop
tôt pour mesurer pleinement et
absolument les effets d'un certain
nombre de départements qui ont rejoint
cette liste
cette semaine et ensuite évidemment ça
n'est pas suffisant aujourd'hui pour
observer une décrue de l'épidémie dans
notre pays puisque vous savez nous
sommes encore à un plateau qui a
tendance à augmenter avec aujourd'hui en
moyenne 17 ou 18 mille cas par jour
bonjour m rien avec europe1 ce matin le
professeur delfraissy a annoncé enfin
annonce a évoqué plus tôt la possibilité
d'un retour à la normale après
l'épidémie à partir du mois de septembre
vous nous annoncez que le commandant
l'état d'urgence sanitaire sera prorogé
jusqu'au 1er juin
dans ces conditions est ce que il est
possible que le calendrier pour les
élections locales du mois de juin soit
modifié et autrement dit est-ce qu'il
est aussi possible de faire campagne
pour des élections régionales alors
qu'on sera encore en état d'urgence
sanitaire alors sur ce point là vous
savez que nous avions confiance confié
une mission à monsieur debré qui a
consulté l'ensemble des formations la
politique à la fin de l'année dernière
qui a remis un rapport avec une
proposition qui a fait consensus chez
les forces politiques pour reporter les
échéances et les élections
départementales et régionales au mois de
juin prochain
il me semble que dans ce rapport et dans
les annonces qui ont été faites par le
premier ministre au moment où il a
annoncé reprendre cette proposition
il est dit qu'il y aurait une un point
d'étape sur le sujet et puis la date
exacte en question le mois en question
mais qu'il qui interviendra aujourd'hui
il est prévu que ces élections aient
lieu au mois de juin comme ça a été
proposée par jean louis debré est
décidée par
le gouvernement j'ai pas d'autres
informations que celle là est d'ailleurs
le projet de loi va être présentée je
crois très prochainement au parlement
pour adopter ce repas quel est le degré
d'inquiétude de l'exécutif vis-à-vis des
variantes du virus britannique et sud
africain est ce que cela pourrait donner
à terme des mesures de limitation
transfrontalière de kehl et adam braz
information est ce qu on dispose sur ses
fameux variant sur ces spéculations
aussi sur des réparations sur ce point
olivier veyrat est l'occasion d'aborder
ce sujet notamment hier devant le
parlement puisqu'il était auditionné par
les commissions de l'assemblée nationale
et du sénat
il ya une préoccupation et une vigilance
absolue de notre part vis-à-vis de ces
variants c'est à dire le variant voc
2020 dit variant britannique et le
variant 510 variant sud africain une
vigilance qui nous a conduits vous vous
en souvenez à être l'un des premiers
pays en europe à fermer les frontières
avec le royaume uni avec une suspension
totale de toutes les traversées pendant
48 heures le temps de mettre en place un
nouveau protocole sanitaire il faut être
extrêmement clair aujourd'hui sur la
situation vis-à-vis des frontières de
notre pays
les frontières extérieures à l'union
européenne sont fermés dans leur quasi
totalité à l'exception de quelques pays
dits verts qui le sont pour des raisons
objectives mais dans la quasi totalité
des autres pays ne peuvent venir et
rejoindre notre pays que ceux qui ont la
nationalité française ou qui ont un
titre de séjour valable un motif valable
évidemment c'est extrêmement limités et
dans ces cas là il y à un test
obligatoire au départ ou à l'arrivée
pour garantir que ces personnes ne
soient pas porteuse du virus est
évidemment des mesures de
d'isolement qui sont recommandés le cas
le cas échéant ensuite la question que
je que je comprends de votre question
c'est que vous abordez aussi la question
des frontières internes à l'union
européenne
sur ce point là on a toujours été
extrêmement clairs sur le fait que c'est
une réflexion que nous avons en
coordination avec la commission
européenne et avec nos voisins
par principe est précisément lorsque on
est dans une situation comme la
situation que nous connaissons avec le
variant voc 2020 qui se diffuse qui
s'est largement diffusée en
grande-bretagne et qui fait apparaître
un certain nombre de cas en europe
les choses peuvent toujours être amenés
à évoluer et des discussions toujours
lieu en ce sens
comment est ce que ça peut faire évoluer
la situation sanitaire en france parce
que olivier verrons je crois que c'est
lui a parlé d'une pandémie dans la
pandémie quel est le degré d'inquiétude
ce soit quel est le degré d'inquiétude
en tout cas enfin là dessus je lis et
veyran s'exprimer sur le sujet hier il a
donné un chiffre que nous avons à date
qui est que 1% des tests pcr qui ont
réalisé détecte ce ce variant dans le
dans le diagnostic nous avons une
vigilance absolue et avec évidemment une
attention particulière lorsque des cas
sont détectés à au respect de
l'isolément et à la remontée des chaînes
de contamination et des cas contacts
pour pouvoir aussi d informer et les
isoler est-ce qu'on est ce qu on a déjà
des prévisions sur la propagation de ce
genre ayant sur se penche pas faire
l'essai mon collègue de la santé
s'exprimer demain lors de la conférence
de presse merci j'espère revenir bon
genre and poor's france télévisions sur
les réformes qu en est il de la réforme
de l'assurance chômage qui est on a dit
devait faire son retour aussi à obo au
printemps et concernant le
le rapport qui a été remis du conseil
d'analysé économique qui préconise
notamment de moduler les allocations
chômage en fonction du contexte
économique est ce que ça retient votre
attention à ce que le gouvernement est
prêt à aller dans cette voie
sur le premier point les choses sont je
crois assez clair la ministre du travail
a eu l'occasion d'en parler récemment la
réforme de l'assurance chômage a été
différée dans son application et on peut
bien le comprendre
face à la crise économique qui découle
de la crise sanitaire
elle est aujourd'hui prévue pour entrer
en application mois d'avril je crois
vous avez dit au printemps je crois que
c'est avril et dans l'intervalle il y à
une discussion une concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux pour son application
évidemment nous poursuivons les grands
objectifs et les grands principes de
cette réforme mais peut-être peut-être
qu'elle peut être adapté au regard des
circonstances
et c'est exactement le travail qui est
en train de mener elisabeth bornes sur
ce point sur la proposition que vous
évoquez je n'en ai pas moi-même
connaissance mais par principe
évidemment que d'une manière générale et
particulièrement en ce moment nous
regardons avec beaucoup d'intérêt et
d'attention toutes les propositions qui
peuvent être faites pour répondre à
cette crise de nos modules et les
allocations chômage en fonction du
contexte économique
je réponds je fais une réponse de
principe sur le fait qu'on regarde
toutes les propositions qui nous sont
faites c'est la ministre du travail de
s'exprimer sur cette proposition en tant
que tel je n'ai pas entendu abordé dans
une réunion que j'ai pu avoir avec elle
ou avec mes collègues et donc je n'ai
pas mon avis personnel sur ce point
bonjour olivier galibert rtl semble
lever le voile sur les annonces qui
seront faites demain parce que il a été
discuté ce matin de l'opportunité de
prendre des mesures à l'échelle des
territoires des départements comme il a
été fait jusqu'à présent ou est-ce qu'il
faut passer à peut-être des choses
annoncée nationalement les deux sont
évidemment tout à fait possible vous
avez vu qu' il y a aujourd'hui dans
notre pays à la fois des mesures de
portée nationale et des mesures de
portée locale
il ya des mesures de portée nationale je
pense au couvre-feu à 20 heures je pense
au télétravail très fortement
recommandée obligatoire lorsque il est
possible dans deux entreprises
et puis il ya des applications locales
des mesures locales je pense évidemment
départements qui sont passés à 18h en
cours au feu et c'est tout à fait une
logique qui peut se poursuivre je ne
parle pas des mesures en tant que tel je
parle du fait d'avoir à la fois un socle
de mesures nationales et des
renforcements au niveau local si c'est
nécessaire
bonjour le luxe ignore ses news
gérald darmanin olivier dussopt pts
alain griset eric dupond-moretti
sébastien lecornu 5 ministre visé par
une enquête judiciaire plus de dix
ministres depuis le début du quinquennat
ont été visés par la justice ça ne veut
pas bien sûr dire qu'ils sont condamnés
ou et qu'ils ont été condamnés mais est
ce qu'à l'heure où on dresse le bilan
des réformes celle de la transparence
voulue par le président de la république
et du changement des usages en politique
pour rétablir le lien de confiance entre
les français le politique est ce un
échec
aujourd'hui selon vous écoutez moi j'ai
été élu député en 2017 jetez pas au
gouvernement à l'époque une des
premières lois que j'ai eu à voter en
tant que parlementaire c'était la loi
sur la transparence de la vie publique
avec un certain nombre de mesures
extrêmement importantes qui ont été
adoptés sur la séparation des activités
que l'on peut avoir
professionnels et des activités
politiques avec l'interdiction de
recruter un membre de sa famille comme
collaborateur parlementaire avec un
certain nombre d'autres mesures qui
était attendu je crois depuis longtemps
par notre démocratie par les français
pour la confiance précisément dans la
vie publique je vous remercie d'avoir
appelé que faire l'objet d'une enquête
ne veut pas dire être coupable il ya la
présomption d'innocence qui s'applique
évidemment dans notre pays et vous
comprendrez
évidemment que je n'ai pas de
commentaire à faire sur l'ouverture d'
enquête sur qui que ce soit dans notre
pays la justice est indépendante elle
fait son travail et je crois a
précisément que si je faisais linverse
l'a peut-être que vous pourriez faire
des commentaires sur
la confiance que l'on apporte à nos
institutions et à la démocratie dans
notre pays
bonjour anthony lattier une question sur
un tout autre sujet sur la politique des
visas il ya deux députés de la majorité
comme ont déposé un rapport aujourd'hui
sur le sujet ils disent en gros que la
révolution de la mobilité promis sur
emmanuel macron à ouagadougou n'a pas eu
lieu et il s'inquiète notamment du fait
qu' il ya un poids déséquilibré du
ministère de l'intérieur dans la
délivrance des visas
est ce que vous seriez prêt à ce que
comme il le demande le ministère des
affaires étrangères soit plus impliqué
sur ce sujet et est ce que le
gouvernement est prêt à délivrer des
laissez passer pour les bénéficiaires du
regroupement familial pendant la crise
sanitaire ya par exemple eu 800
sénégalais qui attendent en ce moment
alors vous avoue aborder un rapport qui
a été remis aujourd'hui c'est ma cote ce
matin dont je n'ai évidemment pas pu
prendre connaissance puisque je suis
depuis ce matin en réunion conseil de
défense conseil des ministres et
séminaire gouvernemental donc je peux
pas me faire de commentaire sur le
rapport si ce n'est que évidemment la
crise sanitaire et son impact depuis
maintenant un an également un impact sur
les mobilités dans le monde et y compris
donc sur la délivrance de visas par
notre pays même s'il ya eu des objectifs
extrêmement fort assumer et affirmée du
président de la république dans son
discours de ouagadougou notamment avec
le dispositif passeport talent
précisément pour accompagner aussi le
développement des pays africains ce qui
en parfaite résonance avec le projet de
loi que je vous ai présenté il ya
quelques semaines sur la publique au
développement pour aider et soutenir nos
partenaires africains pour
leur développement pour ce qui est des
propositions plus précises je n'ai pas
de aujourd'hui de réponses à vous
apporter
simon lebas antre c'était encore une
question sur la situation sanitaire vous
avez j'imagine eu sous les yeux ce matin
au conseil de défense les chiffres qui
vous donne une idée plus précise des
conséquences des fêtes de fin d'année en
particulier du 31 décembre qui
préoccupait beaucoup le gouvernement est
ce que ces chiffres confirment vous
semblent confirmer que les effets ne
sont pas aussi catastrophique que
redouté et en conséquence est ce que
demain les mesures qui seront annoncées
même si je sais bien que vous pouvez pas
dévoilé aujourd'hui peuvent voilà est-ce
que ces chiffres peuvent laisser penser
que les mesures ne sont pas aussi
drastiques là encore que redoutez vous
savez bien que il ya dix ans de presse
demain et je vous remercie de chercher à
m'emmener le plus loin possible dans le
teasing de ce qui pourra être annoncé
demain mais est par ailleurs je je je
conçois parfaitement que vous souhaitiez
avoir les réponses à ces questions
aujourd'hui que plus largement les
français soit à voir ses réponses ils
entendent énormément de choses qui
circulent dans les médias des pistes qui
circulent des pistes qui seraient
explorées parfois des décisions qui
seraient prises sans que l'on ne sache
où vraiment le gouvernement qui a pu le
communiqué sur le fait qu'une des six
que cette décision aura été prise mais
je comprends que ça peut être très
difficile pour les français dit voir
clairement dans ce contexte là pour ces
raisons je ne vais pas moins commencé à
donner des informations partielles ou a
défloré une communication qui sera fait
le plus clairement possible par le
président et le premier ministre demain
ce que je peux vous dire en revanche
parce que là c'est très clair et
évidemment olivier ferrand s'est exprimé
sur le sujet à l'assemblée nationale on
en a reparlé ce matin que ce soit au
conseil de défense ou en conseil des
ministres l'épidémie circulent dans
notre pays elle circule moins fort et
moins vite que chez la plupart de nos
voisins aujourd'hui la france a un des
taux d'incidence aujourd'hui les plus
faibles
en europe tout cas chez nos principaux
voisins parce que les français ont fait
des efforts parce qu'on a pris les
mesures nécessaires au moment où c'était
nécessaire notamment un confinement ou à
l'époque certains nombres vous avez dit
on en faisait trop
la preuve c'est qu'on a je fais là pris
la bonne décision au bon moment puisque
l'épidémie a fortement diminué
ensuite ce qu'on constate néanmoins
c'est que entre je crois à début
décembre et aujourd'hui le taux
d'incidence dans notre pays a doublé
il n'y a pas eu d'augmentation
exponentielle et compris ces derniers
jours à l'occasion des postes fêtes de
fin d'année nous sommes sur sa olivier
ferrand l'a très bien expliqué un
plateau qui a tendance à monter sans
compter aujourd'hui une hausse
exponentielle décrochage dans l'épidémie
mais évidemment nous sommes extrêmement
vigilants vigilants face aux conditions
hivernales face à la situation que nous
voyons chez nos voisins face aux
variants qui circule partout dans le
monde et pour lesquels des cas ont été
détectés en france est évidemment en
nous considérant qu'il faut prendre des
mesures pour continuer à freiner le
virus continue à protéger les français
nous les prenons c'est dans cet esprit
que le premier ministre et le mythe de
la santé interviendront demain merci
beaucoup
à la semaine prochaine